the reason why i was saying hamas was
funded by israel in 1980s
yeah the reason why that's an important
consideration is because the the main
threat at that time was the plo the
palestinian liberation organization
organization and the reason why they
were amazing they had the majority of
the
military capabilities and so on yeah and
so what happened was that there was a
conflict in interest or if there was a
structure
actually there was a no sorry there was
a struggle for power there was a
struggle for power
between hamas and it continues until
this day and the plo right
and that struggle for power the israelis
saw
an opening and they said you know divide
and conquer
if we fund the hamas and we militarize
them then they'll fight each other we
don't have to fight them that could be
yes yeah so it happens so i can't
justify so where
so this the reason why i'm telling you
this
is it's all about narrative creation
knowledge production the reason why
is because the idea of a terrorist if
you look at the
uh if you look at the forties fifty
sixties seventeen eighteen nineteen
twenty
two thousand so on you'll find that it
was more to do with arab nationality
in the 40s 50s and 60s all right it was
about
arab nationalism versus zionism that was
the struggle all right okay
religion played a secondary you could
even say a tertiary
kind of it was a tertiary consideration
at that point in terms of
the politics the propaganda of both the
arab governments not just in palestine
but around it like in egypt
and syria look the the muslim
the palestinians walking around
in the country can't just finish
my point the same actions were being
done okay all of this time
you've got the same problem with america
funding moody and all these things are
you with me
the reason why i mentioned this is
because the same actions are being done
but the explanatory force has changed
the reason why
these things are happening in the 60s
and 70s according to
if you look at just for example the
propaganda in newspaper materials
is completely different to how it was in
90 in the 90s 2000s
it shifted from a nationalistic agenda
to a narrative about religion
and that was cause that coincided by the
way you have to know this
with the ending of the cold war which
happened in 89
and the final soldiers left in 91 that
happened a good 27 28 years ago
so obviously america needed a new enemy
israel
needed to kind of come with america and
they came together
the elites of those countries almost in
tacit collusionary format
to create a new narrative of the muslim
terrorist threat
that happened it was in the interest of
the israeli it was in the is
it was in the interest of an opinion
listen
sorry you're still not thinking as broad
as i want you to think
what i'm saying to you 1979
which is a fact you can find i have the
newspaper clipping
or killing millions yes the fact that's
factual millions of being facts muslims
don't believe
not millions but hundreds of thousands
not even a hundred tens of thousands
thousands i wouldn't even say okay this
is
this is that's not available it's in
iraq syria we're talking about all
different
muslims but even then are being killed
fine so
i agree with you so okay that's what's
up it says what this terrorist and
a lot of that's going through the holy
wars and then and what isis are
proclaiming holy
what's that got to do with the west well
i would say to you you're telling me not
about even
isis so to muslims because nobody could
be terrorists well it's got everything
to do
it's everything to do with the west
because they left the power vacuum
2003 well let me know look at 911
i have a good discussion here okay and
you're just getting over excited
look i'm saying to you i'm telling you
i'm you know i think
well let me let me let you know can i
ask you a question
two planes went into the twin towers yes
yes 911 2
and something people so okay we're back
this guy burnt alive and fell to the
death
right why i could do the west
prototyping muslims well it's got
everything to do with the west if you
look at
if if we bet if we look if we if we look
at the exp
they just add bellum and they just
earned bellow
the justification for war that osama bin
laden supposedly wrote we don't know to
what extent this is
true he wrote this there was a fatwa he
wrote in 1998
and that's what he wrote in 2002 and
then
isaac now you're playing games now you
don't understand now there's a language
barrier
i'm sorry i really don't understand no
well let me explain to you yeah
if you look at his fatwas and his modes
of justification
generally against the west could you
explain can you just give me a giveaway
sorry sorry this is knowledge
information you don't know all right
so you ask me a question i'm giving you
the answer with with data and figures
i'm sorry you should yeah
yes before him and after him how they
justify
the cancelling out of non-combatant
immunity
yes which is the principle that
islamically is upheld even by them by
the way
even by them is upheld the reason how
they cancel that
that principle out of non-combatant
immunity is what they say is
the principle of reciprocity they say
that they're killing our listen
they say osama bin laden said and his
fats were 98. why
why are we killing you because you're
killing us he said in his photo in 2002
the same thing
in other words the reasons why isis can
even exist
is because they justify their acts and
their
terrorism yes through the actions
of the western world according to them
okay according to them that
justifies a person's actions
let's be clear we totally agree on that
point but what i'm saying is if what is
the west
what to do with it according to their
justification methods
they say the west because they they've
come into the us and
the saudi arabia the military they've
come in as military based in saudi
arabia
because of the israel they continually
reference
israel palestine bosnia and chechnya
they are talking about either the west's
um allying with israel or
direct intervention of muslim lands or
acquiescence of muslim
death that is how they've been able to
justify it
in the same way as the christ church
killer was able to justify his murder
in the same way by the way begin
the president of israel hold on excuse
me the president of
the president of israel in his book the
revolt which he wrote which you can read
is a book a primary source material he
says in the beginning of the book
we hate those arabs and he tells
us he tells the people how he went into
villages and killed all the arabs
he justifies his i never justified what
i did did i say that you did it bring
this to me i'm saying that they're
they're just a bellow and just just a
bellow
their modes of justification is
actually the same throughout that the
the jews have the
the jewish terrorists have the same way
the christchurch killer has the same way
and and so does the muslim terrorists
say it's the principle of reciprocity
you're doing it to us
we're doing it to you so from that
perspective they can cancel out
non-combatant immunity
and there can be terrorism so are you in
other words saying that the west is just
as responsible and just as as
no i'm not saying that that's not true
i'm saying that
everyone every terrorist i'm saying
every terrorist every single terrorist
every extremist
every monstrous person that cancels out
this principle of non-combatant immunity
must first go through a justification
program in their mind
and that justification program has to
start with a perpetual conflict
which they propose for themselves we've
been driven out of our land
we've been killed with this with that
and then killing children becomes
legitimate
it's legitimate for isis it's legitimate
for the christchurch killer
for the israeli state my point is that
you can't see
that the israeli government is isis and
isis is the israeli government
there is no difficulty there is no
difference the only difference is
the israeli government where's the
island necessarily uh
i would say i was saying no problem the
israeli government
that's what isis says that's what let me
know that's what isis says do you know
that's why isis says look at their books
look at look at the look at their
magazines have you read what they said
well that's right anyone that doesn't
convert islam gets butchered they start
no that's not they don't quote about
that they don't say that i say that's
what they do
okay isis i'm telling you i've read what
i've read
i don't care what they say i know they
go to everything well well
i can say the same thing about israelis
and killing men
look if that's what i thought it's not
about due date conversion it's about
a genocide it's about getting the people
those arabs out and keeping those
what doesn't mean you're getting those
arrows out but i'm telling you i'm not
necessarily going to be designers i'm
saying as of now that's what's happened
isn't it there is an argument
to do with what is up to they are very
they're living a life i suspect in the
u.s by the way
if they don't do you do you say that
isis is a legitimate state
no okay why not yeah who doesn't think
they are
they're not they're not a legitimate
state because it didn't have on anything
no no you you were saying
israel conquered yes that your
justification for their existence is
conquest
isis conquered their lands you can make
the same justification no
i never said that was a justification
that that the british government if
there is one the british government gave
up
so what's the difference between isis
let's be honest let's be honest you said
the blanket statement yeah
expected me to vibrate that the israeli
government is isis now i completely do
well they have the same justification
it's really do not have agendas to kill
people yes they don't no they don't
they're suspension
listen all these attacks but have you
read it though
no i'm
have you ever been to israel or do you
think i'm allowed in the country like
that
i just met i came back no matter what
i'm not allowed they kicked us back out
man you trust me
trust you i came back just to release a
jet flight from tel aviv to stanster
trust me i can tell you those two people
having a nice conversation
with 10 muslims i know the muslims go
there but not every muslim if you're
affiliated to a charity
that boycotts israel they don't let you
in no one frequency is not allowed
why not because you're a threat to the
country what if i boycott the they don't
either
don't eat the decision
i'm not going to kill you i'm just i'm
saying that you do that you don't have
marriage you pull on the flag in america
they put you in prison why just because
i've just
that's what happens people sorry you put
an american flag not in this country my
friend you can put any
american flag you want here i know you
can't but you burn an american flag in
america
like you said yeah the point i'll make
it to you is this
that if you're what i'm making to you is
right
afraid all these people okay he sat down
with him so the problem is
as of now what did you call it uh osama
bin laden sat down who's with the scia
did he yes in 1979 they were friends
they were good friends of each other
does that mean anything to me what is
that or how's that evidence he i'm
asking
in fact no you know the time you're not
justified the times have a picture of
the calling over heroes all you're doing
is calling israel says i'm asking you
what i'm doing all these reasons i'm
saying that you said i'm asking a basic
question what
do you want six million israeli let's
see let's say you morally correct that
they shouldn't be in the country yes the
problem is what do you want six million
israelis to do now
i think that this is an audition is
calling them assets
they kill people what are you doing is
saying that they have agendas to get rid
of the muslims
i'm telling you now there's a a major
conflict
and it's about it are you asking me a
question you've asked no let me just
finish yeah i'm just finished
i'm not i'm just i'm very calm okay yeah
just give it two minutes
all right yeah that's right yeah yeah
i'm saying people are killing each other
yep
and we know for a fact there are
palestinians who want to kill israelis
have a chance to kill all israelis
okay you know that's that's a fact it's
a given i'm telling you now i'm i had
friends no problem juicing people
you read the israeli newspapers there's
terrorist attacks every couple of years
okay go ahead keep going
well as of now by the way it's not it's
not the case i've looked at the numbers
that's fine
the case i'm telling you facts that i
lived there i've lived i've studied
therefore yeah but
no no no i know you studied there for
the past year that's one year and
seventy years of its history so that's
170th
well what's happened with anything
that's a lot of no no i'm asking as of
now it's like
so you don't really have the full volume
yeah yeah you hear terrorist attacks
left right and center
are you hearing this you do certainly no
no this is fact
yeah well it's usually there's a bullet
i know i know i know if there's a place
called hanov in jerusalem
where uh two years back five the five um
so what numbers are so look at the
civilian casualties of palestinians
that could also be true no hold on let's
look at that let's look at the last ten
years has ezreal ever
just gone and done airstrikes on gaza
without rockets coming before
never how do you know that of course
this rocket so what about what did you
make
for a reason i said you're now
justifying your candidates my parents
lived there in 1992 so let's let's end
this discussion because
i was going to
well the only thing that's clear to me
yeah is that your failure to recognize
that i know you but you you haven't let
me speak man i've been
speaking for a long time you just said
the blanket let me have i've been
speaking for a long time or has it been
quite even actually
okay it could be even but you don't say
that you said it's been even okay it's
been even
right you're saying that's a little bit
discombobulated right now
it could be because this is the show
so the point is that you said that
israel is a terrorist the israeli
government now is a terrorist
organization
what i'm saying is i will not agree
designers i don't agree
and i have and do you know why i say
that i say that look ergon was actually
you just changed your mind
would you mind no no let me just i was
just finishing do you want to finish off
what you're saying
that's exactly what i'm asking you yeah
yeah so what i'm saying is that as of
now there is definitely a threat to the
security security of six million jews
doing israel six million israelis
okay and there's no threat on the
palestinians there is
so which one is more severe i don't know
i'm asking you don't know okay let's
look at the numbers then
let's look at well look at let's look at
the numbers you have
how many people living in gaza how many
people it's the most densely populated
place in the world
i was going to say to you is simply this
is simply this simply this
if you're being honest with yourself
yeah i'm wanting to be i'm very
open-minded yeah if you're very
open-minded
you know that if you look at the fact
that in 1971 whatever it was
the fact that uh begin was allowed to
become
president of the country yo just not let
me speak okay
he was actually one of the people who
you were talking about
911 you were talking about sound biladin
he was part of an
operation which went into a hotel yeah
and killed 91 innocent
individuals in one of yeah it's very
wrong but he was your president
in your country for 10 years or
something like that yeah and then he and
after him the same party which was
actually if you look at his history
with the the lucid party when all
yeah whatever in english we say luke's
party
ludicrous party yes that party which has
its
origins historical origins in a
terrorist organization which is oregon
continues to
perpetrate this terrorist act all the
way up until this time
it's done so throughout the uh the the
intifadas
and up until this point in time all of
these uh
operations that have been done and look
at the casualties of palestinians
compared to the casualties of israelis
there is no compara there simply
is cannot be any comparison it's not
even one that's
because israel is more capable of
defensiveness oh it's not defending it's
attacking that's what i'm saying
and here's attacking who the children if
look how many children have been killed
is that something to be proud of
is that your how many children have been
killed in israel not many actually yes i
do know and not many
that's the answer how many how many how
many how many what are the officials
hundreds of thousands i don't know
hundred thousand not hundreds of
hundreds and thousands no no not even us
if you i
i dare you in the last ten years to find
me a statistic that says
in the last one year that five israeli
children have been killed uh or ten year
attempt
is really true that would be okay it's
not like this man okay it's minimal
it's minimal but imagine but look at the
environment that are dying in it
it's not it's not comparable man let's
go
look you're asking me the question of
the million-dollar question right
okay okay it's a pessimistic future my
opinion right there is no
there's no solution because you have
these competing powers they've all got
interest in that country
that's how it is and let me ask you one
more last question before we pass do you
find
any problem with the palestinians living
in israel do you find
any do you hold of everything that
palestinians users do sorry or you've
got
do you have any problem any problems
with what the palestinians
do in israel you've got you're with them
a hundred percent or you've got yours
certainly with them 100 but obviously
yeah absolutely every single palestinian
every whatever
of course not it is a ridiculous
position for anyone
yeah so i don't know do you write so
there are palestinians that
do want to wipe every single israelite
off the map that's what i'm saying just
like you think about israelis
isaac the truth is most israel most
palestinians main concerns
are their own survival and preservation
that's israelis means persistence
that is what david david coming in from
isaac to london
every couple of nights but david has
become goliath and unfortunately
maybe maybe maybe the holocaust kind of
this is the holocaust industry kind of
discussion
maybe in the holocaust that that kind of
rhetoric would have been totally
acceptable and it is totally acceptable
but what we're talking about you are the
bigger and stronger capable
uh military doing it to these little
groups of children and poor sisters
throwing rocks and whatever
you're you're sorry your case is no
longer bought why
why because you're the it's like me the
government is worried about isn't
innocent israel is being killed i don't
understand you
oh okay well let them be worried about
it's not worried it's a fact this is
interesting
okay let's let them be worried about
that they have a right to be worried
about
everything but here's what i'm saying to
you is that look at the look on the
ground look at the data look at this
look at the history everything shows
that this was a this is a
we are going to government okay i'll
never come with you all right
thank you my friend all right let's go